[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle routine qui semble
s'installer en france
merci d'avancé
s'il vous plaît rer métro annulé on se
dépêche
on se bouscule on s'entasse pour rythme
des messages tonitruante de bénévoles
venus en renfort pour ordonner le chaos
dans les gares avant lui plaît et ça
devient n'importe quand ça devient
ingérable
la contestation des grands syndicats de
la réforme des retraites annoncée par le
gouvernement français entre dans sa
troisième semaine et elle use les
usagers des transports en commun épuisé
par cette gymnastique
une majorité de français se dit malgré
tout appelé ça le paradoxe français
solidaires des grévistes
jusqu'au bout on n'a pas à retirer nos
avantages et après ce sera quoi si on
nous retire notre est il va mettre des
contrats un euro comme en allemagne le
fait de défendre régulièrement dans la
rue et de de se mettre en scène comme ça
comme la france éternelle celle qui
descend enfin celle de la révolution
française celle de la commune celle des
journées 1848 celle de mes 60 c
c'est aussi une manière de se mettre en
scène comme étant ben c'est nous la
france enfin une certaine image de la
france une certaine france sans doute
beaucoup d'explication à ce phénomène ça
tient aussi d'un sentiment de peur
collectif croit la philosophe pascal
bruckner
une peur qui empêche plus souvent
qu'autrement les réformes en profondeur
en france
je pense que le sia la peur de la
mondialisation du mondialisation qu'on
ne contrôle pas la france aimer l'europe
à condition que l'europe devienne
française
pas de chance les européens ont dit non
on veut pas votre modèle est la gare du
nord jean-claude rbi a le loisir de
marcher d'un pas serein cet enseignant
et proviseur à la retraite a tout son
temps pour arriver à destination
la réforme des régimes de retraite ne
s'appliquera jamais à lui mais il la
croit nécessaire même si j'étais en
activité
je serais quand même pour cette réforme
pour d'autres réformes il faut réformer
le pays
enfin je dis je soutiens absolument la
politique de monsieur macro après moi le
déluge lui rétorquerait bon nombre
d'enseignants qui descendent dans la rue
ces jours-ci dans les champs sur les
pancartes c'est beaucoup le président
lui même qui est mise à mal
beaucoup de français ne font pas
confiance à emmanuel macron en partie à
cause de cette étiquette du président
des riches qui lui colle à la peau
il a globalement tous les traits
négatifs du duo yopi comme on dit en
anglais du jeune homme riche banquier
qui a tout réussi et qui prend les gens
de haut donc les gens le trouvent très
arrogant foulée français l'état c'est
vraiment très important l'état est
l'incarnation le représentant le
défenseur le promoteur de l'intérêt
général et donc on attend beaucoup de
l'état on attend beaucoup d'un état dont
on se méfie tout autant ici marie ève et
d'un radio canada paris